so I think one of the marketing
campaigns here in the US that's been
very successful for us has been around
at NFL sponsorship so we're the official
HDTV of the NFL and that gives us
obviously a good association with sports
which is a big passion point for
consumers here but we've really
activated across a number of different
ways but the key there i think is it's
all coming from the passion of consumers
so we went out we've done a lot of
research over the years into why
consumers buy TVs and the number one
sort of purchased driver for TVs around
sports that's what people want to watch
on a big screen TV and it's very
communal you want to have your friends
over enjoy it together and that's
reflected in the way people buy TVs so
we've done big campaign this year with
our large-scale TVs so that you can
really understand the benefits of
watching those TVs to enjoy sports and
bring in the NFL and the football
connection so we were written up
recently in the New York Times for this
as being an example of a very exciting
marketing campaign that's brought
together consumer passion points
together with sort of multi-channel
activation really cool TV commercial but
all of it rooted in the insight from
consumers that this is what is
meaningful to them for watching TV again
it's part of this change from just being
a piece of hardware to being something
that you enjoy a really wonderful
experience and sports now it's just
unbelievable in HD on large screen
I think what it really says to us and
probably as a technology company we need
to learn this lesson more than any other
which is to focus on what really is a
great experience for consumers so the
technology technology companies like
ours it's always easy just to default to
looking at you know the engineering side
of things and this is cool we can make
it thinner and so on but what is it that
consumers really want and what is it
that's going to be just this wonderful
experience for them so you know we spend
a lot of money in samsung now to look at
that wow experience and even looking at
the way in which people unbox our
products there should be that wow moment
when you take the TV out of its box when
you take the mobile phone out of its box
just that sense of excitement of emotion
so it's really moving from technology to
being about emotional connection and
that's where the marketing campaign
comes in to
yeah you know we had products a few
years ago when I was working in Korea
where it was really at the early stages
of convergence so putting things
together and saying let's take a phone
and let's put a camera basically
together with it and that was like the
first camera phone some years ago and
that notion of just putting things
together really focused on technology
and then pushing it into the market
those things often didn't sell very well
why because consumers didn't really see
a need for them and also because they
sacrificed product so we want getting
the best product features and the best
functions that consumers wanted so
sometimes when technology isn't aligned
with where consumers are and it's just
pushing a technology solution to a
problem which they don't feel they have
then that's where I think we we can get
we can get in trouble but the more we
rooted in really understanding what
people are buying what their unmet needs
are what sort of goals they have really
from their their products that's where
we can build successful marketing